in my words and bear witness to my vow
now gathers and now my watch begins it
shall not end until my death
I shall take no wife hold no lands
father no children I shall wear no
crowns and win no glory I shall live and
die at my post I am the sword in the
darkness I am The Watcher on the walls I
am the shield that guards the realms of
men
I pledge you my life and honor to the
Nights Watch for this night and all the
nights to come
what's up ladies and gentlemen let's get
right into this today in its video I
want to give you another alternative
theory that's opposed to the popular
belief about how the night King and his
army is going to get south of the wall
and decimate the Nights Watch
ever since season 1 episode 1 I think
we've all been wondering when the others
will actually breach this wall the
opening scene of the series introduces
us to the Nights Watch the wall and the
threat beyond the wall and I remember
thinking when I first saw this episode
if these mysterious creatures ever get
on the other side of that wall everyone
is going to be [ __ ] now that the
series is nearing its end the threat of
them passing through the wall is greater
than ever
we haven't been exactly sure how they
would get south of the wall but the show
has been foreshadowing this event from
the very beginning in season 1 there are
several different theories floating
around about this but I think one of the
more obvious answers was foreshadowed
several times during the series and in
one of Jon Snow's dreams but no one
seems to be talking about this being the
way that the others gets out of the wall
as of right now I think the most popular
theory is that bran will be the reason
the wall loses its magic which will then
allow the night King and his army to
pass through and get south this isn't a
bad theory actually but it might not be
the right answer
bran has been marked by the night king
ever since they cross divisions the
night King was able to reach out and
physically grabbed him by the arm and
that mark allowed the night King to
track bran wherever he went and also
allow him to cross through any magical
barrier that once kept the night king
and his men out there is a very good
chance that bran is permanently
marked by the night king we did not get
a good enough explanation about this yet
and since the children of the forest put
magical spells in the three-eyed Ravens
cave and the wall it's not a bad
assumption to think that the knight
king's mark will have the same effect
anywhere that the children of the forest
magic is present but there are other
ways the wall can be breached which
we've seen happen before by other
members of the cast according to the
plot League it says that the made king
will knock down the wall using one of
Daenerys his dragons that he allegedly
kills and turns into a white dragon
there is zero evidence of this happening
but since this would be all done with
CGI there would be no way for this to
leak unless someone on the inside leaked
this information which is possible but I
don't think this is the way it's going
to happen someone also asked me on
Twitter a few months ago why the night
King didn't go after John at hardhome he
walked to the end of the dock raised the
dead then he let John get away some
people have also been wondering why the
night king and his army just don't go
around the wall which would probably be
the easiest way for them to do it but my
guess was because of the salt water as
we know salt melts ice and the body of
water they would have to cross at the
wall is salt water and you could say the
night King is so cold he could freeze it
anyway but him being so cold could be
another reason why he didn't get too
close to the water maybe the water would
instantly freeze if he got in the water
or on the water in a boat which would
then just freeze him stuck in place in
the water that would actually be pretty
hilarious some people even think the
wall could get knocked down and
advertently ever since Jon Snow said
this to Eddie
don't look it down while I'm gone I'm
doing the back look that could be some
foreshadowing - and let's be honest
visually it would look amazing to see
that wall come down but I don't think
this is enough evidence for me to
believe that this is the way it's going
to go down but let's get to the heart of
this discussion now and I'll tell you
why let's put those more popular
theories to the side so I can show you
all the evidence that points to the
night king and his army climbing over
top of the wall not through it not
around it but climb right over top the
son of a [ __ ] we've already seen people
climb this wall so we know it can be
done in the night King and his men have
superhuman strength so they could
probably climb the wall without even
using any kind of climbing gear they've
also already shown us a scene at
hardhome of exactly what it's going to
look like when thousands of whites come
pouring over top of the wall this has
been foreshadowed in almost every season
of the series Jon even has to dream
about this in a dance with dragons let
me preface this by saying this dream can
be interpreted in many ways but I'll
read it to you and let you decide
it says burning chefs hist upward
trailing tongues of fire scarecrow
Brothers tumbled down black cloaks
ablaze snow in Eagle cried as foam in
scuttle up the ice like spiders jon was
armored in black ice but his blade
burned red in his fist as the dead men
reached the top of the wall he sent them
down to die again some people could
think dead men reaching the top of the
wall just means they are inevitably
going to die that's why they were
referred to as dead men but it says John
will send them down the wall to die
again so to me that means those are
White's climbing the wall while Jon is
standing on top of the wall looking like
an absolute badass dressed in black ice
what they sword burning red in his fist
and when these dead men reach the top of
the wall Jon sends them back down again
a die more than likely these are
wildlings turned into whites we know the
magic prevents the whites and White
Walkers from coming through the wall but
it doesn't mean they can't get over top
of the wall legend says that no one can
cross the walls magic unless they're
with a brother of the Nights Watch so if
that works
true and the magic prevented people from
climbing over it then the wildlings
would never be able to do this when they
go on their raids so this leads me to
believe that anyone can go over top of
the wall if you're brave enough to climb
in the wall being climbed by others was
foreshadowed all the way back in season
one
Sam Tarly even warns Jon Snow Pip and
Grenn about this most of the books say
to White Walkers sleep beneath the ice
for thousands of years and when they
wake up and when they wake up what
I hope the Wolves how you know Sam said
he hopes that the wall is high enough
because he's afraid they're going to be
able to climb number top of it and later
on in season 5 after John gets back from
hardhome he fears this scenario as well
with Sam he raised his sons and they all
stood up at once tens of thousands of
them the biggest Tony in the world what
you gonna do I'm gonna hope they don't
know how to climb the wall I think this
is the answer ladies and gentlemen
they're going to climb the wall
John is afraid of this because he saw
exactly what they are capable of just
like I've shown you in the previous
scene at hardhome John saw just how easy
it is for the whites to rain down upon
you when they reached the top of the
wall they can literally jump off the top
slam into the ground and break apart
then put themselves back together again
within seconds I think we could see this
happen once again the night King White
Walkers and their army of whites getting
south of the wall is inevitable we've
known this will happen eventually since
their very beginning but in my opinion I
think the best and most evidence we've
gotten thus far is them actually going
over top of the wall they've only
referenced the wall getting knocked down
one time but since brain allowed them
into the cave via the night Kings mark
this scenario is fresh in our mind the
night king could very well put his hand
to the ground and split the wall just
like you did to the cave once bran
crosses it of course I still can't rule
that out but then going over top instead
has been hinted at the most in my
opinion John dreamt that this happening
and John has climbed the wall himself so
he knows it can be done and Sam and John
both fear that they can climb the wall
so this will be the scenario I'm leaning
toward the most some people even say
that the night Kings mark was a one-time
deal and they may be right about that so
if that's the case and they're going to
need another way to get south so I won't
be surprised if we actually see them
climb the damn thing can you imagine
what the scene would look like hundreds
of thousands of White's climbing the
wall with the night king and his top
lieutenant white Walker standing by his
side
as they are on top of the wall
overlooking Castle black as the horn is
blowing three times over and over again
we see the Nights Watch men
look up at the top of the wall then
right as we see all the whites leap from
the top it cuts to black in season seven
ends do you know how [ __ ] hyped that
would be knowing that one season eight
begins we're going to be in for one hell
of a ride but these are just my opinions
and stupid daydreams so you might not
agree with me but comment below and tell
me what you think is there enough
evidence in foreshadowing for you to
believe that they're going to climb over
the top or do you have any other theory
that wasn't mentioned here I would love
to hear it if you do let me know your
thoughts about this also don't forget to
check out my last video about all the
characters I see surviving until the end
half of those subscribers have them
watched it yet so definitely check that
video out I think you're going to like
it and I want to give a shout out to the
golden company family when season 7
begins we're going to be making group
videos across all four channels with my
friends gray area cows fukken chickens
and secrets of the Citadel we're forming
our own group to do some episode reviews
breakdowns predictions and stuff like
that so hopefully you all look forward
to that and if you're not a fan of
collab videos which I know is the case
with some of you don't worry because
I'll still be releasing solo videos on
my channel as well and just as
frequently but this should be a lot of
fun working with them those are all
three great channels that I subscribed
to and watch all their videos they each
bring something interesting and fun to
the table so I can't wait to start doing
some collabs with them and one last
thing before I go I got to give a shout
out to my patreon supporters I can't
thank you all enough you generous people
that pledged have almost raised enough
money for me to buy a camera for the
channel so I can start making some
actual videos on screen I have a few
different ideas I want to do with the
channel once I'm able to get the camera
that I need so seven blessings to those
of you that have pledged but all of you
listening and watching this have shown
me tremendous support over the past six
months you've helped me grow this
channel beyond anything I could have
ever imagined I really appreciate all
the love I'll see you all down in the
comment section bye